welcome
glad to be with you it's been a while
now I know there are a lot of questions
and obviously uh you know been the rumor
mill circulating which we'll probably
get to later in the show but there are
some important questions regarding the
you know future of mug Club since we've
done the press conference Alex Jones
Hodgkin's new people here uh and I think
one of the most important one and if
you're watching on YouTube right now I
would encourage you to go watch on
Rumble for reasons that will be
glaringly apparent in approximately 20
seconds is hey we see that YouTube has
cracked down on some things they seem to
be getting more strict going into
election time and some of you have been
worried
or at least asking us if we'll be
pulling back
um and uh to that I answer
with this
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
friends
back back
[Music]
[Applause]
sudden death among healthy working age
people worldwide is skyrocketing she
died here at the hospital after she went
into cardiac arrest who knows young
people are dying these are not
statistics these are human beings
[Music]
[Applause]
because I represent science
[Music]
are you willing to share the data with
this committee we had to really move at
the speed of science
in your head in your head
you smell
[Music]
friends
relax
[Music]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithkreider.com mug Club gain
access to an unrivaled catalog of
unapologetic and entertaining creators
including the Hodge twins Nick depalo
Brian Callan and of course Alex Jones
all that and everything you see today is
entirely funded by viewers like you for
89 annually join the fight at louder
with credit.com Mud Club today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
ah
well that's nice
we're back that's nice to be back with
you there's so much to get to a lot of
developments and if you are not watching
on Rumble right now ah please go do so
because the next thing you might see
might be the uh the going beep
this channel no longer exists it really
shouldn't be comment below you really
think that's a reason
ah what happened to satire parody but uh
hey that's not really something you see
out there so uh we're gonna be getting
to uh a lot here today there's a tick
tock I don't know this Tick Tock psyop
that's been going out out there trying
to destroy marriage here in the United
States since the lady put her put her
put her hand through the ring it's like
Lord of the Rings and then seven days
later she's miserable and single
uh we have a this week in Biden we have
an exclusive from the new mug Club
undercover unit the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital and what they've
been doing uh targeting your well yeah
kids yeah targeting kids I think
transgender operations for kids and
they've just were rated the best
hospital or Children's Hospital here in
the United States the reason for that we
have a a circulated email exclusive
because our eyes and ears are everyone
then we have Alex Jones guesting uh but
first in while second in command CEO Mr
Gerald Morgan how are you sir I'm
fantastic I I wanted to get back on the
air and then it felt like a football
game for me today I wanted to run
through a wall not like Alex Jones right
split his chin open but like I wanted
how are you I'm sorry I'm excited good I
got a lot to get to yeah we have a lot
to get we'll get to it yeah all right
now we're talking to me for in third
chair do we have theme music because I
don't know if that's which one we're
going uh uh there it is here we go slide
that in all right
I wouldn't say that those of you who
don't want your pops crowd are all up in
your videos you got Pops Crowder in
third chair and then you have in fourth
chair today we have uh two people you
know them you'll love them you can go
see him at the Funny Bone Richmond
Virginia this Friday Saturday August
18th and 19th follow them at Josh
underscore firestein just firestein how
are you sir
this is a wonderful start nice yeah yeah
I'm doing good how are you I'm good
you're gonna get a network network out
today because you have to go back and
forth yeah I love it I keep going back
and forth I'm playing footsie with your
dad right now yeah yeah but I don't tell
anybody you said two men two guys yeah
he did say two guys in fourth chair in
fourth chair well third and fourth all
right
you know what just all off the top here
let's uh let's again there have been
since we've been gone
they've been the rumor Mill's been
circulating I know a lot of you have
been asking me questions
um so I'm gonna try and address this I
guess as uh as tactfully as we can and
Gerald you can just say shut up but
um there have been a lot of story it has
been brought to my attention uh that
there have been some stories out there
circulating
um some old some new regarding uh
divorce that's been going on obviously
I've been going through for a very long
time we have not discussed this and I
want to be very clear this is under
confidentiality from the court from the
judge and I will honor that so I won't
be discussing that and I would caution
anyone by the way on either side
any side whether you think you're
helping me or someone else just from
drawing conclusions on what would
necessarily be incomplete information
because of the situation now as it
relates to some other rumors you know in
hit pieces unrelated to divorce so like
a recent hit piece this is something
that uh
yeah I need to address that I have ever
committed to adultery and I say
unrelated to the divorce because the
media smear campaign is of an accusation
that has never even been alleged to be
clear in any divorce proceedings nor
allegations of any kind of physical
abuse ever all right
this is a complete falsehood out there
in the media from people who are looking
to do reputational damage and we know
who's behind it uh I want to be very
clear about this I have absolutely
and unashamedly respectfully courted
several women well since well since I
was served divorce papers
and I've been going through a separation
and divorce for well over two years
depending on how you calculate it and
each of these the reason I need to
address this is because each of these
women uh are incredible
they've all been incredible conservative
God-fearing women to the letter
have done nothing wrong
these were not one-night stands these
were meaningful relationships with each
woman who's well aware of my situation
well after served divorce papers who do
not deserve to have reputations
besmirched who helped me through what is
what has been the darkest most difficult
period in my life and I have a fondness
in my heart for
for everyone involved and by the way
the woman would make fan these would
make fantastic wives mothers for whoever
ends up being their husband someday who
finds themselves in far more reasonable
circumstances uh and I want to be clear
about this dude now look I understand
that some people out there think um you
should never date anybody Court anybody
until uh divorce is finalized in the
case of uh Gerald has a yeah so so uh
yeah I won't say who but I know somebody
who went on for 10 years there's
currently and there's this going on
eight years you know this is well over
two years and it could go on forever I
understand that some people have that
point of view I do not
I do not uh and I think it's important
to find something real
um it's something that I still believe
something that I that I want by the way
uh and um this is also uh why especially
looking for something real we are now
going to announce the win a date with
Stephen Crowder sweepstakes
Put Me In Charge baby it'll be a test
holiday look-alike contest so send your
send your resume and by the way uh of
course no no pornography though erotica
no is tolerated nope lizzo's not busy to
date Stephen louder with crowder.com
that's date Steven at ladder with
crowder.com again looking for something
real real meaningful relationship uh as
long as you have a BMI that's between
anorexic and morbidly obese between the
ages of 26 and 38 years old if you're
okay with a man who's pretty boring
outside of work my only Hobbies really
include family food film and reading I
like the beach but not long walks on
them but
I make up for this by being tall
so send your
resume.com for the win a date with
Stephen Crowder sweepstakes uh you look
so young there
I know well look I have to put my best
foot forward
and I will say this though and there
have been other hit pieces and smear
campaigns and the owners have to address
that because again you hate seeing
people drawn into something who have
done nothing wrong yeah
um I have been humbled and I do have a
lot to apologize for look let me be
really clear here I was wrong
about a lot
uh to men out there who have been going
through divorces and we've had these
questions come in at life advice um I
understand look I hear you now there's
not just a problem of pervasive feminism
to be clear
but the failure of the church
we were talking with a pastor recently
who was on the show who had an assistant
pastor who at this church was forced to
step down because someone left him while
they were cheating on him yeah because
he was ashamed of being a man who had
been uh divorced and I was made very
aware of the fact that look there are a
lot of women out there and I hear you I
see you
uh
who also aren't on board with this it's
not just a woman-hating club where a lot
of people are tart and feathered the
men's rights people out there The
Advocates when they're talking about
custody laws I understand where they're
coming from I understand where you're
coming from I see you and if you expect
me to change my tune on marriage right
this is something that speaking to
marriage in general
um I want to be really clear this has
been unbelievably painful
and again there's just complete
necessarily incomplete information out
there as it relates to marriage
um I get that there are some people out
there who become bitter who become
anti-marriors and I see that in the
men's rights groups out there let me be
really clear about something my opinions
haven't changed
I believe that a child needs a mother
and a father in their house ideally to
raise them that's incredibly important I
believe that marriage is the Bedrock of
society it's the foundation of American
society before State governance before
Federal governance you need
self-governance and that comes with a
strong nuclear family I still believe
that and I believe that we need to fight
to preserve that in this country now
with all that being said
I may never get married again
what do you do with people like me
and I know that there are a lot of men
out there who love women who are scared
and I am so genuinely so sorry if I was
ever dismissive I hear you I was wrong
comment below what experiences that you
have been through because you'll
probably find other people You Are Not
Alone
um and uh you have someone who will be
an advocate as it relates to
strengthening families going forward in
this country specifically as it relates
to laws and people who have had to go
through this system for years you do not
need to be we often say Hey you know you
shouldn't be ashamed publicly you should
not be shamed because something didn't
work out and a choice that wasn't yours
so
um I apologize really do and if we ever
get another question on life advice from
a young man who is successful who saved
up some money and wants to try his hand
at love
but he's concerned
about being fleeced
you're never going to hear me be
dismissive or spout talking points that
I think are culturally sort of ingrained
in the church that aren't necessarily
biblical so
apologies as to some other rumors that
have been circulating again it's been
not one hit piece after let's just get
it off rip off the band which by the way
I think I left one in Texoma there this
weekend because I saw water snake and I
I ran and scraped myself a little head
out that scares the hell out of me I
thought you were gonna say you ran so
fast the Band-Aid came off well I did on
a rock and then I need another Band-Aid
uh as to other rumors out there yeah
look yes yes the general NDA at the
company of course yes to it being
reinforced in the company when when
you've had former employees and people
when I was being paid for leaks and of
course a confidentiality or like I said
that I will honor in the court we have
strengthened it yes all of that is is
can I at least address some of this
stuff finally well we've we've had kind
of the muzzle on but we've been taking
hit after hit I just don't want the
whole show to be about no no no we won't
do it on the show I'll do it on Twitter
go to my Twitter account right now I'm
not going to address every crazy person
with an egg but I'm going to address
some of these issues that you guys have
asked for trust me right now just not
right now you can do it on your Twitter
on my Twitter do it on your Twitter look
it's one of those things where we don't
deal when have you ever heard me talk
about specifically former employees or
what goes online no that's not what we
do here unfortunately we're just not
going to sit there and take it and take
the arrows in our back anymore you can
talk about it I don't want the show to
be about that go and follow Gerald I
appreciate it hopefully you guys can
like comment below share this as we move
on with the actual content of the show
is it too much is a grandfather to not
want my or my kid my drink its sleep to
be doxed out there is that okay is that
information we can control I think
that's fair tonight
that was unreasonable maybe yeah
especially when kind of what people are
thinking the calls coming from inside
the house yes oh so we'll leave them I
do and thank you pups creditor a big
reason you've been put through this too
for a couple of years and uh look it's
one of those things that's uh the court
says to keep it private and I have a lot
of respect for the court and the judge
uh so I'm not gonna be addressing that
but I also uh see where everyone else is
coming from now uh before we move on I
hate that we do this but we've done it
for years
um so it's one of those things since we
were gone you know a lot of news
happened we have to recap I just don't
like
we're stuck on this we still have to do
it we still have to do it yes
California reparations San Fran public
urinations
Still A Flock just like that Mulvaney
Indiana Jones sucks so thank God for the
writer's strike
[Music]
is on the way Elon says that zucker's
gay Gavin Newsom defense cops forcing
kids to boost her shots Lindsay Lohan
had a baby Megan Fox's batch crazy
[Music]
no we didn't start
those are Ray episode Fox News White
House had some Road booze no wait that
was cocaine we all know who is to blame
zelinsky slams NATO RFK should clear his
rope Rhonda sent us Donald Trump Justin
Trudeau steal a cut
yeah
Tony Bennett R.I.P whistleblower on his
knees Snow White is a Mexican a dude is
Miss Netherlands Air Force One has
smaller stairs hunter in his underwear
Donald Trump might go to jail Jim
caviezu faces
[Music]
fight we don't want it but if you want
to fight you better believe you've got
one
[Music]
[Applause]
I get it you're gonna say oh hack You're
Gonna Start the Fire yes yes yes yes to
all but we if we don't do it then some
people get mad and me a lot of people
were asking for it I'm surprised I know
I think it's because I like to torture
us uh question a day here what are you
most excited to see from uh the new mug
club network comment below and I tell
you what when we were doing that press
conference Alex Jones went into Alex
Jones mode I watched Brian Kellen and
Nick to polish and I go oh that's why
he's Alex Jones yes there are levels to
everything yes there are levels to this
game you can see in his head where he's
like I haven't yelled in a long time
I knew I saw that pissed up I was like
he's gonna say something dude it's gonna
be awesome this boy shouldn't get like
this from being calm
uh he's going to be on the show a little
bit later on by the way to lead into uh
his show yeah really it's great because
in the Reel you hear his old voice you
wonder where was the inflection point
where that changed yeah I don't know I
was just 75 yelling matches later
are you doing like a G Gordon Lydia
where he would hold his hand over a
flame only was his throat he's like I
don't flinch
your Mud Club if you have some chat
questions for Alex he's going to be on
later in the show and then when we go to
Mud Club we can ask some of those
questions yep keep them nice
I mean sometimes so uh over the weekend
too and we haven't even gotten the news
yet sorry we're 20 minutes and I hope
it's like there's so much there's just a
log Jam and then Alex Jones is like get
out of her all right so over the weekend
I haven't seen this clip because they
told me not to watch it okay uh former
factory worker Oliver Anthony took the
Internet by storm with this song
Richmond north of Richmond
Texas
look out for minors and not just miners
on an island somewhere
ain't got nothing
Wildfire but God if you're five foot
three and you're 300 pounds taxes don't
not to pay for your bags of fudge rounds
young men are putting themselves six
feet in the ground cause all this damn
country does is keep on kicking them
down
men are putting themselves six feet in
the ground because all this damn country
does is keep on kicking them down
thank you
and you know what it only works because
it's a fantastic song by a guy brimming
with Talent yep but it never be said
that gingers have no souls
wait wait we've said that yes I know
over and over I regret it I regret it
today I stand corrected there's one say
to the the rich men that are uh north of
Richmond uh come on down south to see me
this weekend
[Laughter]
Richmond Virginia
good for that guy yeah no I mean he's
speaking true why is it that country
music is the only place that you can
speak no it's not the most of them are
phony most of them are phony sons of
I'm just saying but the audience
wants it yeah exactly no this is Outlaw
country in other words this is real
country by the way Nashville just so
you're clear it's just like Hollywood
only with people who wear cowboy hats
and by the way they wear cowboy hats
fake it's fake they're not Cowboys
guy like this this is real I hope this
guy I hope this guy blows it up I think
they were literally number one now it is
on iTunes yeah I saw that yeah they will
write a fake backstory for country
artists like they do for rappers yeah
exactly that's the main streets of
Detroit I've been shot five times okay
well I grew up in a horse farm in North
Carolina I like muscles
you guys heard Jason Aldean's song too
yeah
no hit but he I mean if these are the
kinds of things where we do we do comedy
we do entertainment we do news but we
can get removed from YouTube that right
there could get removed from you that's
the problem YouTube Facebook Spotify
right Apple all of these things happen
with Alex Jones first that's why mug
Club is what we do that's why this is a
live show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern you can watch it on Rumble it's
still going to be free the first hour of
the show but none of this happens the
free show unless you sign up at lotto's
credit.com and we want to be able to
support guys like good for that that
guy's unbelievably removed for being a
ginger yeah that could happen too it's
always funny when the hair kind of runs
away from the ginger but the beard
remains yeah you're like your brother
your brother's a great example yeah it
is yeah it's it's a little I mean let's
be honest a little unsettling all red in
the beard and the heads are different
what are you doing pedophilia there
Jeffrey Epstein Island he hits like
obesity this is the we didn't start the
fire version of a country song he
basically is hitting all these major
cultural points that people are just out
there thinking about and talking about
daily and he just nailed it and here's
the thing too it's not just like people
talk about Fox News and you've heard us
talk about big con like when you talk
about Jason Aldean's song it's not just
that a couple it's that everyone at
Viacom and CMT they didn't realize in
other words they these people in charge
of these networks they see you as a
walking wallet with teeth right it
requires someone like this to break
through the noise independently and it's
it's not the artist though sometimes it
is it's the people at the top then it's
often artists who make their way to the
top this happens with comedians this
happens with singers this happens with
producers I mean is there any more
conceited song that's ever existed and
Faith Hills Mississippi Girl it might
know me all around the world yeah I'm
sure they know about you in Ghana shut
up
Pearl Harbor sucked yeah
big line dancing fan the movie or the uh
the movie in her song I think she was
using a clothesline in it I don't know
all right that's great soundtrack yeah
okay
it's a tick tock uh right now there's a
psyop going on as it relates to marriage
something that I don't know about we'll
be discussing I didn't see this coming I
thought it was just just the feminist
angle yes okay so let me so at first you
would just think it's a feminist angle
and let me know you can comment below if
you've seen this and if you thought
um the country with one child policy
yeah yeah they're behind it
and they got no strings oh we didn't say
Tim everyone's a little bit trigger
happy today
so over the week I need to set it up
okay this is the problem it's not the
conference and I don't use prompter I
just like usually point to him
uh I was ready for it over the weekend
uh there's this video that's been uh you
know showing The Perils of marriage and
again couldn't disagree with it more do
not let yourself uh become bitter just
because of one bad experience but we do
need to fix something so the Perils of
marriage this video it went viral on
Tick Tock and Twitter to influence uh
many young women wrongfully
so she sees her future
wow she really hates a clean house and
children apparently I hate to be her
plumber me too I'm taking this off but
she is now fabulously wealthy yeah
well if she leaves uh let's have her put
on the pass ring where she's in college
listening to an afro lesbian Professor
talk about women's rights were you
fulfilled there laughs
here's the one thing look let me before
before we get to this this is something
I call the 99 and 99 rule okay it's over
40 of young and maybe uh gender snap
back there you can get me these stats
it's like over 40 percent of young men
out there who will never get married
yeah I think it's 60 of women who say
that there aren't men worth marrying
because it's really cool to put up Tick
Tock videos when you're 20. and then you
realize oh hold on a second it might
have been nice to have children and you
know doing the dishes every now and then
wouldn't have been too much to ask
um
ever women's share and Karen strong uh
has been on the show I I we should
probably have her back their share of
household duties has gone it's never
been lower but they've also never been
more unhappy in other words there's been
a lie that's been fed to American women
and we'll get to how this lie is Being
Fit now because the Communist Chinese
party is getting in on the action but
here's a big reason that men and women
are missing each other okay and and you
can comment below
and it's been on my heart obviously a
lot lately uh men haven't changed what
they want in a woman
okay that's still that's why you see
billionaires marrying waitresses
they don't care about your college
degree they don't care about your job
that's not what matters to a man man
still wants the same thing that he's
always wanted he wants a nice woman to
whom he's attracted to come home and be
able to do right
to feel safe to have a safe haven nice
matters more than money right nurturing
matters more than business success women
have changed a lot of what they want
from men that has changed significantly
and a lot of men feel like they can't be
mind readers right and you know that
this is true because it's a stereotype
that everyone jokes about when it's
funny right if a woman says she's not
mad it means that you have to find out
why okay I call this the 99 and 99 rule
right now if you're watching and you are
married okay woman man all right let me
ask you if you're a woman
you're married to me okay let's assume
that he's the primary provider at one of
a more traditional relationship doesn't
mean he's the only provider
does your husband uh does he come home
to you every night the answer is yes
okay does he protect you
okay if something goes bump in the night
does he answer or do you lock him in the
bedroom all right does he provide
meaning does he go to a job at all okay
we've just crossed crossed a threshold
but I'm not going to tell you what one
more question does he ever listen to you
complain about problems ever that don't
affect him does he ever do anything nice
for you like send you flowers even if
only on your birthday if the answer to
those is yes congratulations you are
with a man who's doing more than 99 of
men who have ever lived
Everly do you think Genghis Khan was
listening to you about Tiffany no
because those things they were expected
to provide and protect okay now on the
flip side you're a woman and you're
married to a man let me ask you this
do you cook for me do you cook every day
if the answer is no you are now doing
less than 99 of women who've ever lived
from the beginning of time up until
1964.
doesn't mean that you have to I
understand that there's a division of
labor now if you're both working but men
still want the same things let alone if
we get to the idea of taking care of the
house of being supportive of him
sometimes maybe people have to drop
their priorities for their spouse that's
what happened this is a very new idea
it's the 99 and 99 rule you've changed
what you want from men and obviously
this woman doesn't want any of the
things that traditionally was seen as a
wife doing doesn't mean a guy can't take
out the trash what I'm saying is this
girl's gonna look I'm script you can
have a Roomba
we're trying out loud Glade sells the
shower cleaning thing they do have you
ever have you ever done laundry with a
washboard do you have any idea what that
would be like with a washboard and you
have to dust in and sweep through no
swiffers let alone a god-forsaken Wet
jet
like it's cinderelly cinderelly
you're using a ShamWow
well I hate the part she's holding a kid
and she's like ah this is miserable it's
like come on children are some of the
most their work don't I understand that
my Saturday and Sunday were totally
different Saturday very difficult very
difficult we have kids they're very
young Sunday fantastic they loved us
they wanted to hug us and it was great
it reminded us why we liked them it was
fun but it is the most joyful thing and
you're portraying it as a ball and chain
that shackles you to where I've never
felt my heart swell up for anything in
my life the way that it has for my
children no it's just this it's one of
those things people say it and you Josh
probably same thing yeah yeah I just put
my kids in front of the iPad
what are you doing yeah of course yeah
don't put the ring down put an iPad
location services
done it's 20 23. come on
give that kid a tick tock already but
again it doesn't it just doesn't take
into account all the joy that's brought
with it and the truth is women then
reach their 30s or their fours going oh
my gosh this is not what I thought life
was going to be like yeah well because
you know you thought that running a
broom was the equivalent to being a
uyghur in China so
just leave it to weird
write that down
right now Eddie Haskell's just a CCP spy
trying to sell cigarettes
all right
so the video was actually uploaded by a
Chinese Tick Tock attack account now to
be clear I have no problem with the
Chinese just to be clear especially like
ginger Snapback people to Chinese
Chinese people and food because I love
the Chinese people I hate the Communist
Chinese party so the Twitter user at
grit cult noted that the video contained
multiple products with Chinese writing
there's a shirt there's cooking oil and
the woman in the video
um appears to be what they call a white
monkey Josh is going what we're not
talking about I'm sorry Urban Dictionary
defines us as a person who works in Asia
normally China and whose qualification
for the job is nothing more than being a
Westerner and normally Caucasian the
Urban Dictionary also says not normally
applied to black people oh surprise in
China yeah they're known for being
hospitable to every yes and going back
to what I said before I do look this the
reason we have marriage laws in this
country is because it's foundational
right the only way that you have a
self-governing society is you have
strong families and that's why the
Communist Chinese party has been pushing
an anti-marriage agenda and propaganda
in the United States for a very long
time while actively subsidizing marriage
in China because their birth rates and
their marriage rates are at record lows
so they want American marriages to no
longer take place while they increase
theirs because they understand that that
does create a robust Society now of
course there should not be enforced or
mandated marriage or relationships
whatsoever what I'm saying is that China
understands as a political prescription
they need to have strong families if
they're going to have a strong Society
so they drip drip drip tell you all
married
miserable yeah isn't that crazy though
so merry man
this feels like a smear campaign right
now I don't appreciate it to be honest
with you yeah
[Laughter]
he looks exactly like the gorilla from
Congo that is not our fault all right he
absolutely does but he's not black what
he's going to say is that China
understands that families are the
foundation the Bedrock of a culture in
society and if you want to be successful
the family has to be strong isn't that
strange we've been saying that for a
very very long time and we are actively
working against ourselves by saying that
they're not the foundation of our
society and we're destroying families
right now women in China by the way are
having kind of that same issue 24 was
the average age of marriage now it's 29
and they're doing everything they can
China is they got rid of the one child
policy and like we'll let you have three
yeah right nobody in China is probably
gonna have more than two or three kids I
understand that but they're still in
control they're still putting you think
they're Chinese women liberating them
like like it's time for the get off the
and commit already I'll get
off the park I have no rings exactly
they want him to marry earlier so
they'll have more I Wanna Rock I want a
diamond they're actually gonna short I
don't think so they're too busy working
yes I gotta find one
actually thinking about shortening the
school year or the the overall education
time in school for women so that they'll
have kids I'm not kidding them the
Chinese party they're very creative I
don't like them they go down the tunnel
of love like folded paper swans yeah
they could just send their kids to my
school I had all kinds of pregnancy
they're like all right you've been in
school for 11 years that's enough you're
done I don't know we're going to a hand
of sex education like the United States
they hand out condoms they're just like
it's like swiss cheese I don't know
there he is I don't know
well look I know we holes in condom make
I go faster
better pump better stroke volumes
Alex is here and ready for us I know we
have him kind of earlier today so I
thought we had him at uh we had him at 9
45. I said to have him no I know we may
have to get to Alex ten and we may have
to get to Alex in just a minute do you
want to do this we can buy anything well
because we also have the exclusive we do
can I can you check and see if Alex can
call us back in a little bit because we
need to get to The Mug Club we're
running late hours stuff we're gonna
have to get used to fellas just so you
know I said
Alex I love you I love you but I said I
said uh 10 if you can if not then that's
okay but we do have an exclusive from
Mud Club undercover which is the first
time we want to break but before that
he's he's like okay that's fine all
right okay thank you Alex we love you
thank you that's a stronger lead into
your show hey everyone hit the like
button or tell Alex Jones that you love
him that you're happy and hey by the way
I know a lot of you uh are like oh Alex
Jones don't care
guess what we're gonna stand in the
pocket for our friends hell yeah and by
the way with Alex Jones Nick de Paulo
Hodge from stick to Paul's been on the
road for years he said do you have any
idea what they would find if I'd be done
for the first open mic put it in a green
room I've had three Twitter unless
you've murdered raped or pick-pocketed I
don't care doesn't mean that you should
lose your livelihood I love the people
we're associated with pickpocket
you know it's just a theft one of those
is not like
a skill I'd love to find out that a
comedian in our community was a
pickpocket that's right that'd be
fantastic that was the coolest comedian
oh yeah I don't remember that uh that uh
Club manager in Louisville
I don't like a newspaper what happened
to my pocket watch and not stealing
jokes actual items yes oh there we go
you carry a pocket watch
who doesn't use it to test what is this
bleakers drink he also wears a monocle
though he's gonna go get his haircut
over here
all right uh we'll move on here uh last
week Joe Biden traveled to Arizona we
have this week in Biden often but this
is just one that we absolutely had to
address he was announcing a new Grand
Canyon monument and of course he said
some he said just not some stupid things
but things that I didn't fully
understand the first time I watched it
until I realized how nonsensical they
were so that brings us to our newest
edition of this last month but this week
in Biden
a problem figuring out whether you're
for me or Trump and you ain't black your
Grand Canyon one of the Earth's nine
wonders wonders of the world
literally
think of that there's a you know it's
amazing
[Music]
she walked up and she said Mr President
would you take care of bears is for me
and I didn't know what she meant when
she said it you take care of bears ears
for me well we took care of her and we
gave her the signing pen oh wait if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black did that man just say Bear's ears
well if I get I mean who reminds me of
that old classic from Bachmann Turner
overdrive
well they were Canadian
S I love it I love it they have
Grizzlies up there what a stupid person
in a silly country that that man is
president
it's our fault why not really why are
they being building a monument to a
monument I don't even know what he's
saying that's a fair point Josh yeah
it's a fair point oh this Grand Canyon
no one's going to come see it we better
yes build a statue yes put a sign up
that says big hole yes
I don't know what I read today it's like
putting party hats at Easter Island
Taco Tuesday
it's a beer pedal bus
let me teach you about The Druids
how many weeks of vacation would you
guess
for Joe Biden in two and a half years oh
I know this number's High I got four
days which I was really happy with we
had a great time on the lake yeah what
did he get uh two and a half years gosh
people you're probably going nuts in the
chat my guess is uh nine weeks nine and
a half weeks what are your thoughts
Gerald
it's 104 weeks I don't know like 30. I
think he's had some really giant number
40 weeks wow
vacation wow
that's almost public school teacher
he really pulls a schedule that guy yeah
I'm sure he's working from Camp David
wow no all right
so this is something else here um we've
talked about D and this is where we get
to uh something exclusive here and by
the way none of this happens if you
don't sign up at later with credit.com
to get the wonderful hand etched girthy
mug we have an announcement regarding
the changing of the mug obviously is now
the network has The Umbrella has grown
so large so you're only going to get
this OG for so long uh but this
investigative journalism that we do
um it's one of those things where
sometimes you may not realize it's
entirely funded by you not a lot of
people want to do journalism these days
they want click bait so
we're pretty proud of some of the work
that's been put in we've talked about
Dei near the diversity Equity inclusion
right taking over industries from
Airlines to education now unfortunately
it's found its way to hospitals so
remember that when you hear about the
speed of science or you hear about
trusting the science right now we have
new exclusive Insider details that paint
I don't want to say there's a grim
picture uh that you need to see here as
it relates to the state of Children's
Healthcare this is Mud Club Undercovers
you can't do that without an NDA though
right that's that's fair everyone should
know about everyone who's undercover so
um
[Laughter]
sign everywhere jerks
gonna happen you can follow Gerald on
Twitter
so there's been an increase right in the
emphasis on uh the you know de every
time I said diversity Equity but you
understand we've talked about it less
emphasis at the same time on Expert
opinions right so the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital I'll call it the CCH
moving forward Cincinnati Children's
Hospital it's now been ranked number one
by U.S news and World reports okay
now here's the thing that's now ranked
number one
thanks to an Insider at the hospital
um the mug Club Investigation Unit
undercover has some exclusive details
there was an internal email that we
obtained and it was written by the cch's
chair of Pediatrics uh Tina L Chang
MD so here's Dr Chang congratulating her
staff via email and it tells you why
this is happening this year they the U.S
news World reports increased the weight
of commitment to best practices and
commitment to you can bring it up
there's an overlay and commitment to
equity diversity and inclusion and less
weight on expert opinion now she says
that like it's a good thing
I'd like a second opinion but then it
won't be waiting second opinion yeah
because we got a black guy
our number one ranking recognized our
dedication to quote changing the outcome
together now
we're gonna get to the uh transgender uh
procedures for children and how that is
included here because that's a big part
of Dei just to be clear Dei basically
includes anything that's evil
Progressive for Progressive sake so as
per the U.S news World reports right uh
their methodology expert opinion is
obtained by a survey of reputable
Physicians this is another component
that's important well who what defines
reputable pay date of the document until
2007 the Pediatric rankings relied
entirely on reputational surveys of
board certified pediatricians in
Adolescent Medicine Specialists
continuing to rank Children's Hospitals
solely on expert opinion for an inter
inter
indeterminate period while performance
data were codified and the means of
collecting and verifying them settled
was felt to be unacceptable what that
really means is so we were doing this
based on actual expert opinions out in
the field yeah and now we've decided
that that really isn't the best way to
determine how we should be taking care
of children Ergo it's not the best way
to determine the best children's
hospital right so and you can comment
below if you see where this is going
because there's a lot more to this that
frankly surprised a lot of us and
smashed the rumble button if you're
about to say something because when my
child is hurt again I have two very
young children I want to make sure that
we are being inclusive right at the
hospital I I just want the best outcome
I don't care if it's all men all women
all black lesbian women all black
lesbian men if that's even possible I
have no idea it's possibly a thing next
week I don't care I just want them to
work and fix my son yeah well here's the
thing so the weight of Dei jumped up by
over 16 percent and the weight of expert
opinion according to their methodology
all references available at lotto.com
dropped by 13. so up 16 and down 13. wow
significant think about that for a
second in other words what matters more
now is the diversity is is the snapshot
the Burger King kids club picture that
you put out there look we got a black we
got a ginger we got a lesbian we got a
trans isn't that doesn't that make us
the best hospital no how about your
mortality rates here's something else
Cincinnati Children's Hospital they've
even created a trans Health Center oh
Lord
and the people who have been at the
center of uh I guess the founders of
this Health Center uh this is bone
chillingly scary again this is the Mud
Club Undercover the work that they put
in all of our references are available
lot of cutter.com Link in the
description because some of this is not
publicly available it's exclusive to us
right the trans Health Center is quote
funded by love
and generous donations from Chris and
Jessica kitchenelli so who are the
kitchenellis well they also these are
the biggest donors biggest donors trans
Health they also have to be owners of
the Pure Romance sex toys oh oh oh I've
never been to that website for sure he
was brought into pyramid by his mother
who founded the business in
1983 uh so they sell sex toys what's
more kid-friendly than these fine
products let's bring this up yeah I
think that's about him I think we have
overlay F2 and F3 oh yeah there's Lube
oh that's jelly that's jelly put it with
peanut butter Like a Virgin oh geez okay
God and these people are also founders
of the living with change Foundation
which supports trans children and of
course their own child came out as trans
uh at eight years old so you now have a
hospital being rated as the best
children's hospital in the country by
their own admission this private email
that we have now circulated not because
of their outcomes not because of them
looking out for the best interest of
your children as a matter of fact that
they're starting a trans Health Center
they may be actually actively harming
your children based on the data that we
have available uh but because they're
diverse enough and some people who own a
sex shop are willing to front some money
to ensure that your children have the
same kind of transitional treatment that
their eight-year-old child did by the
way we have exclusive footage from the
press conference that was held at the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital
welcome cold handed ones it's an honor
to greet slash welcome so many who have
touched so many women in such a powerful
way
come on in
watch out it's a little slippery and if
you think it's hot out there whoa
come on come on
we had some time on our hands those are
some good looking legs they get their
own uh Health Center the trans health
and they can't their own bathrooms
children yes do they will happen they
can't get their own bathrooms
but Cincinnati you know we can't do that
they have their own bathrooms yeah in
Cincinnati their biggest concern should
be if the father's not being there in
the hospital yeah well also I mean you
have Cincinnati that I think they have a
good zoo I remember that too Cincinnati
Zoo is really good they have a water
it's at the hospital it's like a water
Drive-In that is where you sit in a tube
and you watch a drive-in film that's all
I remember about Cincinnati really yeah
huh
it's the best worst place to go in Ohio
yes
Erica's 32nd best state and they have
Cleveland yes that's true
and a river that cut
I just I can't believe that
you know how people got out of your
Lexicon you can I ca I can't believe all
right I am shocked yet not surprised
people that are funding a children's
hospital are sex shop owners we could
not have written it that way and people
believed us they would have been like no
that's kind of look I understand that
you're saying that this is like a
pedophile movement and everything like
that but I'm like but
yeah you know what's gonna happen it's
like when a doctor writes a prescription
they go and you can also go to the
pharmacy and get these whatever
probiotics you know what's gonna happen
like uh By the way when you have the
sections operation you can also go to a
pure romance and get the uh his and her
heating gel let me write this down here
sir and if you're ever missed your dick
you can go get a strap off yeah exactly
I mean it's just like the real thing
you'll never you'll never be able to
tell us not there
used to just take a rubber clown's nose
to yeah
something else I won't say it
where did you put the clothes
that's the knob
ah it squeaks all right now I'm right do
we have him uh ready to go oh yeah all
right okay so uh there you go you guys
can comment below and again check the
references thank you so much uh to help
help with the support here uh at mug
Club Mud Club undercover does not happen
without you and we never would have been
able to help re-platform the next
gentleman but uh you can watch them of
course on mug Club on Fridays but you
can also watch from Mad maxwell.tv or
watch his live stream I believe on
Rumble now as he's going to be using
quite a bit more it's time to bring on
the man himself the Supernova the white
whale Alex Jones
[Music]
Jones can you see and hear me sir
it's good to be here very exciting a lot
of people were very very excited and are
excited about the big announcement last
Tuesday we're getting a great response
from folks going over to Jones
crowder.com and I'm not just going to
launch this new
multi-hour show on Fridays very soon
we're going to start
gas analysis PowerPoints you name it so
I'm going to be doing a lot of stuff
this is a
foreign
[Music]
no no no no
more
[Music]
thank you oh Alex mad maxworld.tv uh at
12 I believe yeah noon Eastern what's
what's on your radar what are you going
to be talking about here today what do
you think people most need to know about
well I'm going to shoot it on Wednesday
and maybe even Thursday I've got special
guests coming in just for the Friday
show the maiden voyage uh with your
great operation
and it's going to be the Deep dive on
Bill Gates and who funds him who
controls him State Street and BlackRock
that have 88
of the public companies
in the world they have a controlling
interest in so people ask what is the
New World Order who's controlling the
agenda who's pushing transgenderism and
open borders the end of the family and
War it is State Street and it is
Blackrock both of them together have
over 15 trillion under management
somebody talking about that on my show
today I'm going to be talking about uh
the captured children you know just like
when the Romans would Shack areas of
Germany or France thousands of years ago
they were then parade the spoils that
they had captured in parades into Rome
we have footage of the quote gay pride
parade in Austin this weekend with
hundreds and hundreds of little children
being paraded like captives at the front
naked men dancing around stuff like you
see in San Francisco this is a sick evil
cult we're going to be covering that
we're going to be covering the fourth
imminent indictment of trump out of
Atlanta Georgia we're going to be
hitting just a massive amount of
critical information also all over I was
gonna ask you about the indictment
because this is something that you you
know we have in common and with Donald
uh with President Donald Trump you know
obviously we've been the target of a
smear campaign lately we were talking
about this and you were as well where it
wasn't happenstance that you were
de-platformed all in the same day people
out there don't necessarily know the
reason that they've impeached Donald
Trump twice right and they create these
new indictments is so that they can then
use it when they say well look twice
impeached and x times indicted president
former president Donald Trump and you
say well hold on a second that's because
you made that up that's because you
trumped up those charges right that's
what happened with you they create a
scenario that then they accuse you of
doing well Alex Jones you did this you
go well a second that's actually not
what I did that's actually not what I
said and they use that particularly if
they can sit you in court and ask you
about something that never happened I
think people need to understand they
either want they want you to view this
as he must have done something wrong to
be impeached twice or to be indicted
however many times by the time we get to
an election or it is fabricated from the
ground up in order to make you think
that way and that's something that
you've been through and we've run into
this too I think it's important a lot of
people just don't think that that
happens
well that's right they've had New York
Times articles where former employees
say that I came in their office and
grabbed a goldfish out of the
tank and ate it there's never been fish
here
we'll all sign affidavits I love fish
I've got fish at home I've got a salt
water tank that I've had for 10 years in
love but but that's from Wolf of Wall
Street so they make up something so
crazy that it must be true and then
that's what they put out there yeah no
that's exactly right and then they sit
you down they go uh Mr Jones you know in
court they go is it not true that you
ate a goldfish you're gonna well the New
York Times reported and now the the only
legitimacy they have are the people they
work with who they send out to create a
hit and that's one thing I do think is
is happening with Donald Trump and you
know what I think that in a certain I
know we've talked about this where I
think there's some baggage I think a lot
of people out there the reason you're
seeing the polls change is because
people are going screw you I see what's
happening Cheryl did you have something
you wanted to jump in on yeah yeah I
just wanted to bring that up Alex I
think they can't beat you on your
message right and so what they've done
is they've tried to distract you this is
almost like the political kind of
campaign strategy we just have to knock
you off of the message so much that you
you can't talk about it and then they're
trying to bankrupt you right same thing
that they're doing with Donald Trump
they're trying to distract him by all
these these you know the impeachment
stuff obviously was part of it the the
Russia Russia Russia was part of it when
he was in office and now they're doing
the same thing and trying to make him
spend so much money and time fighting
these things that he can't campaign
effectively well doesn't seem like it's
working doesn't seem like it's working
with you either
well as long as we don't give up we're
going to win we had a six-year war with
the most powerful Empire of the world
had ever seen that started in 1776.
George Washington lost 95 percent of the
battles he lost battles for five and a
half years and then he won at the end
via perseverance and so this is a
marathon this is not a Sprint it's going
to be the turtle not the hair that wins
it and as long as we have fun and warn
people and tell the truth the globalists
are losing power populism and free
humanity and and the Christian
Resurgence is gaining power that's why
they're in full panic mode trying to
accelerate their entire agenda just to
overwhelm us but as long as we don't get
overwhelmed as long as we don't get
violent we are winning the culture War
the globalist owned documents admit it
you see it everywhere you see the
numbers uh people are asking why Vivek
ramaswani is so popular now up above
DeSantis if you tune into what he says
it sounds like a cross between Stephen
Crowder and Alex Jones I mean he's
talking Black Rock New World Order uh
globalist you know pushing place shots
on us he's talking about 1984 and the
answer being 1776 and that's extremely
popular because we are the mainstream
what America was built on what it stands
for is the Renaissance we are the best
system we're not trying to go back to
what America was America was the
Vanguard America is The Cutting Edge and
there is a powerful corporate Revolution
to buy up all the companies and set up
these esg's and social credit scores to
force us to follow their edicts but as
Humanity becomes aware of it of the
censorship and the surveillance and the
debanking and the control that you guys
just went through last week became a
huge story when Nigel farage got
de-banked you guys got dbank last week
for bringing me on but you had backups
this is a war but we're not victims when
this happens we just keep getting
stronger and stronger as Nietzsche said
that which does not kill me only makes
me stronger as long as we have the
support but listeners you keep hammering
and it's so true Stephen it's so true
Gerald if listeners and viewers don't
understand that they literally are the
brains the eyes the muscle the guts the
bones the will of this operation and
other Independent Media operations but
this is the biggest and best there is
then we're going to lose but if people
get excited and realize this is an arm
wrestling match with a new world order
and they put their will behind it we
will slam their fists through the table
yeah no I I couldn't agree more I really
do appreciate too obviously you're
you're Zeal and you know what what
bothers me is when you don't have enough
conservatives out there doing that in
other words this idea of they said they
would kill me last we have to stop when
people like Vivek right the kind of
things that he's saying or this country
song we just talked about this Virginian
man these are things that most
mainstream Americans agree with but
would never be permissible on YouTube
and so or on Facebook or on Twitter we
have a lot of people now have had their
stuff removed from Twitter banned
accounts from people who worked up has
been surprising when conservatives
aren't echoing what people who are
watching and listening right now uh when
they're not doing that then that's when
uh if we allow that to be the Baseline
if we accept that as a new normal that's
when we lose and that's a big reason why
we're so excited to have you here and
Nick I mean you just look it's a who's
who of people who just don't give a
rat's ass anymore and uh for people to
sign up and get your mug it's at uh it's
jonescrowder.com is that your your
landing page there Alex
absolutely when people go to
jonescrowder.com then we get uh the
Lion's Share of the funding you guys get
a small amount to help fund your
operation and hell I've even talking
about trying to do a bigger percentage
deal so we can have you guys build up
your infrastructure for what I'm doing
but I intend to take that money then and
actually hire a couple extra crew
members because I hit a second wind at
about eight or nine at night I do my
show till 2 P.M every day then cut ads
deal with business stuff court stuff
family stuff then I go home eat dinner
at about five six o'clock put my
six-year-old daughter to bed at about 8
30. I hit a second wind usually watch a
Netflix movie or you know I play pool
with my wife but I really usually want
to get back on air then so I'll let
listeners know what my plan is but I'm
not a super technical guy I've built a
little studio in my house I need another
little shift that shows up at my house
at like nine o'clock at night and most
nights I'm talking about seven days a
week that's what you need us I don't
want you to burn out Alice
I'm gonna do another show well whenever
I feel like it I'm gonna do enough so we
gotta get all that hooked up so I can
dial in live but also have you know a
couple crew members there so they can
then put Clips out and stuff so I intend
because my enemies want to silence me
to now do even more broadcasts more
events and and just absolutely give them
everything I got yeah well and we're
excited but I do want you look Alex I
want you to pace yourself because you're
important and we need you out there and
just to be clear everyone out there I
did not ask Alex to say these things or
ask him to do a nighttime show I would
never ask that I would rather he be
sleeping uh but I but this this is a guy
who what you see is what you get with
Alex that's one thing I will say for all
the attacks out there what they try and
do is steal your name and people who
tried to go out there and Alex Alex is
going to get him like he'll often give
me a compliments and I'll get him I get
sort of uncomfortable Alex won't say
this if you attacks that were out there
in the media the one that was potential
it would have been the most damaging if
people bought it was when they tried to
say oh he said in court that it was all
uh performance that it was all an act no
no no no no no no no no that's not true
what they said is not every restatement
if it's allegorical it's meant to be
taken literally unmute the microphones
here before we go to mug Club Gerald uh
pops Crowder Yakuza Tool Man Tim is Alex
exactly what you expect him to be in
person exactly 100 exactly yes what you
see is what you get that's one thing I
love about him I've never seen anyone
more authentic Jones crowder.com we are
going to go to mug club and continue uh
Alex right now for another few minutes
if you are watching on YouTube or on
Rumble sign up at 11.com we will be
taking your chats YouTube thank you but
Rumble thank you YouTube piss off
foreign
[Applause]